Grazie.
Mi ci sto abituando, che delusione quando non lo farete più.
Allora siamo arrivati alla seconda puntata del nostro viaggio attraverso i grandi autori russi del Novecento e oggi parliamo di una donna, di una poetessa, di una grandissima poetessa.
Una che non ha preso il premio Nobel, anche se da vecchia ci sperava, chi la frequentava negli ultimi anni, negli anni Sessanta, dice che ogni tanto se ne parlava.
Lei diceva sì sì, un Nobeluccio quasi quasi.
Poi non le è arrivato, poteva benissimo arrivarle. Anna Akhmatova è indiscutibilmente uno dei grandi poeti mondiali del Novecento e naturalmente la sua vita attraversa, come quella degli altri autori di cui parliamo in queste sere, attraversa un secolo terribile in un paese terribile.
Poi potremmo anche dire un secolo grandioso in un paese grandioso, sì sono vere tutte e due le cose, però oggi fa più impressione quanto fosse terribile quel secolo e quanto fosse terribile quel paese.
Anna nasce nel 1889 vicino a Odessa, ma non è di lì, nasce lì per caso, perché la famiglia è lì in ferie, non sono meridionali, sono russi del nord, di Pietroburgo.
Vivono a Pietroburgo per qualche anno, poi quando Anna, no no, per qualche mese in realtà, Anna a pochi mesi quando la famiglia dalla grande città si trasferisce nel sobborgo di Tsarsko-Yeselò,
il villaggio dello Zar vuol dire, è dove c'è uno dei grandi palazzi imperiali e Anna passa lì, la Tsarsko-Yeselò, la sua infanzia, la sua prima adolescenza, fino a 16 anni,
siamo ancora nella Russia degli Zar, prima della guerra mondiale, prima della rivoluzione, l'ambiente lo dovete immaginare, una residenza della corte,
un posto dove vivono ricchi e nobili, signorine per bene, educazione rigida, scuole private, insegnanti di francese,
e la sua famiglia appartiene a quel mondo, lei nasce in quel mondo. In Crimea, al sud, come dicono i russi, ci vanno d'estate,
come tutte le famiglie ricche di una volta, di quei tempi, per tre mesi, per tre mesi si va via e si sta in vacanza.
Anna ricorda un'infanzia pagana, tre mesi al mare, mi chiamavano la ragazzina selvaggia, perché camminavo scalza,
andavo in giro senza cappello, una signorina di buona famiglia, capite bene, negli anni dieci,
mi tuffavo dalla barca in mare aperto, fa sempre impressione vedere come la grande borghesia viveva già all'inizio del novecento,
come viviamo noi oggi, mentre il grosso del popolo viveva in condizioni totalmente diverse,
e invece i ricchi vivevano, appunto, andavano in barca a fare i bagni in mare.
A Zerskoi e Selò ci sono appunto palazzi imperiali, grandi giardini pieni di statue di marmo.
Una delle prime poesie di Anna, ragazzina, si rivolge proprio a queste statue dei giardini imperiali.
Freddo, bianco, aspetta, anch'io diventerò di marmo.
Ed è vecchia racconta che poi nelle vacanze, siccome continuavano ad andare in Crimea,
e un giorno la mamma le ha fatto vedere la casa di campagna, la Dacia, dove lei era nata.
E lei subito, un giorno qui ci sarà una targa, la madre ovviamente la sgrida,
che razza di volgarità, tu ragazzina, farti queste idee.
E lei da vecchia faceva finta di vergognarsene di questa storia,
e lo diceva che scema che era, che pretesa scema.
Però lo raccontava, naturalmente.
È un'infanzia privilegiata, in una famiglia aristocratica, che non è però una famiglia felice.
I genitori si separano presto, e lei in realtà non ha avuto un buon rapporto né col padre né con la madre.
Prova a provare ancora per entrambi, in realtà.
Oh, Anna Akhmatova non è il vero nome, è uno pseudonimo per pubblicare.
Lei si chiamava Gorienko, Anna Andrievna Gorienko.
Ma quando pubblica, il padre non vuole che il suo nome venga sporcato,
comparendo sui giornali, comparendo sulle riviste, questa volgarità.
Quando venne a sapere delle mie poesie, mi disse, non infangare il mio nome.
Non so che farmene del tuo nome, gli risposi.
E decide di scegliersi come pseudonimo il cognome della bisnonna, Akhmatova,
che è un cognome di origine tatara.
La bisnonna era una nobildonna russa, di una famiglia nobile di origine tatara,
russificata da tanto tempo.
Però in realtà nella leggenda familiare c'era qualcosa di più.
Nella leggenda familiare questi Akhmatov, antenati, discendevano niente meno
che da un Khan tartaro del XV secolo, il Khan Ahmad.
Io anche ci ho creduto per un po' di tempo, poi ho trovato testi che dicono
non è assolutamente provato, è una leggenda, però Anna ci credeva di discendere dal Khan
tataro discendente a sua volta di Gengis Khan, le piaceva moltissimo.
Testimonianza di Anna.
Il Khan Ahmad, il mio antenato, fu assassinato una notte nella sua tenda da un sicario russo.
Nel XVIII secolo una principessa Akhmatova, Raskovia Yegorovna,
sposò il ricco proprietario terriero Yegor Motovilov, il mio bisnonno.
Sua figlia, Anna Yegorovna, era mia nonna.
E io sono stata chiamata Anna in suo onore.
Io ho le dita sottili, ma il suo ditale non mi entra.
Ora, questa Russia, della fine dell'Ottocento, dei primi del Novecento,
in cui nasce e cresce questa ragazzina viziata,
è un paese estremamente contraddittorio, è un paese immenso,
poverissimo a livello della vita, delle moltitudini,
e al tempo stesso con un'elite non solo molto ricca,
ma anche colta, internazionale, giovane, che viaggia, che conosce il mondo.
È come se vivessero due razze diverse dentro quel paese.
Devo dire fra parentesi che anche l'Italia di allora era un po' così, eh?
Perché anche nell'Italia di allora i contadini e gli operai
vivevano in condizioni di incredibile povertà
e invece ovunque, in ognuna delle nostre città e cittadine,
c'era una borghesia e un'aristocrazia colta, con case piene di libri,
che andava a teatro, che aveva le biblioteche, che andava all'estero e così via.
Anche il nostro paese era un po' così.
Una cosa che colpisce è come da giovani già i ragazzi di quel mondo diventano indipendenti.
Anna, a 21 anni, si sposa, siamo nel 1910,
con un ragazzo, diremmo noi, di 24 anni,
a 24 anni, figurati da noi oggi, ecco,
un suo compagno di scuola al ginnasio di Tsarsko-Yeselot,
salvo che il ragazzo, si chiamava Nikolai, Nikolai Gumilyov,
a 24 anni era un poeta famoso,
aveva studiato a Parigi,
aveva pubblicato a Parigi una rivista letteraria,
aveva viaggiato in Italia, in Africa,
e l'ha corteggiata per anni,
la leggenda,
forse cominciate a capire che quando si parla della biografia di Anna,
i fatti e la leggenda non sono sempre facilissimi da distinguere,
lei è arrivata a una certa età e raccontava volentieri,
va a sapere,
però la leggenda dice che appunto Gumilyov l'ha corteggiata per anni,
e che ha minacciato anche il suicidio,
pare che sia un fatto che poi qualche tempo dopo c'è uno che si suicida effettivamente per amore di Anna,
su Wikipedia almeno è dato come un fatto verificato,
lui no, lui non si suicida Gumilyov,
Anna alla fine lo sposa,
secondo la leggenda appunto perché non ne poteva più di questo,
in realtà la testimonianza della poesia di Anna
e anche della poesia di Nicolai,
perché anche lui, anche Gumilyov è un poeta,
è un bravo poeta,
è la testimonianza di un amore furioso ma ma infelice,
da tutte e due le parti,
si sposano a Kiev,
perché Anna è stata appunto a Tsarskoe e Selò fino a 16 anni,
poi i genitori si sono lasciati,
la mamma con i figli si è trasferita a Kiev,
e si sposano a Kiev,
i genitori di lei non vengono,
non viene il padre che ha abbandonato la famiglia e ormai se ne frega,
non viene neanche la madre che è contraria a questo matrimonio,
Anna a 21 anni si sposa lo stesso,
il matrimonio si rivela subito disastroso,
perché? Perché si tradiscono tutte e due,
hanno delle altre storie, hanno delle avventure,
litigano furiosamente, si mollano, si riprendono,
vi cito un esempio di poesia di quelle di Anna
che raccontano di questo amore infelice,
una poesia del 1911,
naturalmente tenete conto,
in traduzione italiana le poesie di Anna
sono una pallida ombra di quelle che sono nell'originale,
principalmente perché la grande poesia russa del Novecento
è tutta rigorosamente in rima e in metrica,
con una ricchezza di rime strabiliante,
la lingua russa permette di fare delle cose incredibili
e in traduzione questo si perde.
Strinsi le mani sotto il velo oscuro,
come mai oggi sei pallida?
Perché gli ho fatto bere aspra tristezza
fino a ubriacarlo,
come posso dimenticare?
E' uscito barcollando,
storcendo la bocca per il dolore,
io correvo senza sfiorare la ringhiera,
gli sono corse dietro fino al portone,
ansimando ho gridato, scherzavo,
è stato tutto uno scherzo,
se te ne vai io muoio.
Lui sorrise tranquillo e crudele
e mi disse,
non prendere freddo.
Ma anche lui scriveva poesie sul suo amore per Anna,
poesia di Nikolai Gumilyov sul suo matrimonio con Anna.
Dall'antro del drago,
dalla città di Kiev,
non ho preso una moglie,
ma una strega.
E pensavo, è divertente,
intuivo, è capricciosa,
un allegro uccello canterino,
si ritrae come un riccio,
tace sempre e sta male,
mi fa pena,
colpevole come un uccello ferito,
come una betulla minacciata
sopra una palude maledetta.
Essendo le cose a questo punto,
il marito se ne va in viaggio
per sei mesi da solo in Africa.
I soldi non sono un problema, evidentemente,
arrivano da tutte le parti.
Anna torna da sua madre a Kiev
e poi decide di andare a Parigi.
E va a Parigi perché l'anno prima
ci sono stati un viaggio di nozze,
1910,
e lì Anna
ha conosciuto un giovane pittore italiano,
sconosciuto, senza un soldo,
che si chiamava Amedeo Modigliani.
E si sono visti qualche...
Lei era in viaggio di nozze, eh?
Però come non è,
si sono visti, secondo Anna,
in quel primo anno non è successo niente,
però lui si è innamorato disperatamente.
Dopo che lei è tornata in Russia,
lui le scrive un'infinità di lettere d'amore,
in francese, naturalmente,
parlano in francese fra loro.
Vous êtes en moi comme une hantise.
Voi siete dentro di me come un fantasma.
E secondo la versione di Anna,
è durante questa sua assenza a memoria
che lui la disegna.
Fa un'infinità di disegni di lei,
nuda.
Secondo lei, appunto,
li ha fatti a memoria quei disegni,
anzi li ha inventati,
ma comunque.
Fatto sta che l'anno dopo
lei torna a Parigi da sola,
il marito è in Abissinia,
torna a Parigi da sola
e lì hanno davvero una storia,
lei e Modigliani.
E lei stavolta ci rimane presa anche lei,
ne parla.
Parla di questo in tante poesie.
Poi alla fine lei deve tornare a Pietroburgo.
Come si siano lasciati,
non lo sappiamo,
però sta di fatto che lui a questo punto
non le scrive più.
E lei invece aspetta che Modiglie
le scriva.
A un certo punto lo raccolte da qualche parte,
aspettavo una lettera
che non arrivò,
non arrivò mai.
Vedevo spesso quella lettera in sogno.
Strappavo la busta,
ma la lettera era scritta
in una lingua incomprensibile.
Oppure diventavo all'improvviso cieca
e non riuscivo a leggerla.
Lei invece scrive,
scrive di lui,
gli dedica versi,
però si è portata a casa i disegni.
I disegni glieli ha regalati lui.
Lei si è portata a casa
16 disegni di Modigliani.
Poi li ha persi quasi tutti
durante la rivoluzione
e gliene è rimasto uno.
E quello le è rimasto per tutta la vita.
Ancora da vecchia,
a Mosca,
negli anni Sessanta,
appeso sopra il suo letto,
c'era il disegno di Modigliani.
Intanto è tornato anche il marito,
Nikolai,
Gumilioff,
si rimettono insieme.
Lei rimane incinta.
Dato che lei è incinta,
lui pensa bene di andare di nuovo
in viaggio da solo.
Lei rimane tutta l'estate del 1912
da sola,
aspettando di partorire.
Il primo ottobre
nasce il loro unico figlio,
Liev.
Di questo figlio di Anna Akhmatova
e di Nikolai Gumilioff.
Liev Gumilioff,
ne parleremo ancora
perché ha avuto un suo ruolo
anche tragico nella vita di Anna.
Passerà anni nei lager di Stalin,
il figlio di Anna,
e poi nella seconda metà
della sua vita,
faccio un po' questa parentesi,
diciamo,
tanto per presentarvi
questo personaggio.
Nella seconda metà
della sua vita
il figlio di Anna
e di Gumilioff
diventerà un etnologo
famoso,
molto controverso,
molto discusso,
che ha una sua teoria
secondo cui
la civiltà russa
è più asiatica
che europea.
Deriva più
dalle steppe asiatiche.
Chissà se c'entra qualcosa
è il suo antenato leggendario,
il Khan Ahmad.
Quello che è sicuro
è che questa teoria
piace moltissimo
ancora oggi
nei paesi dell'Asia centrale,
dove infatti
Liev Gumilioff
è,
trent'anni dopo la sua morte,
famosissimo,
per dire,
l'università statale
del Kazakistan
è intitolata
a lui.
Però il rapporto
di Liev
con la madre
sarà terribile
perché lui
l'accuserà sempre
di non averlo voluto,
di averlo respinto.
Sta di fatto
che appena nato
lo mollano
alla suocera
e marito e moglie
se ne vanno di nuovo
in viaggio
da qualche parte.
Anna in tanti anni dopo
dirà
ma sembrava
la cosa giusta da fare
io e Nicolai
volevamo provare
a riattaccare
questo bambino
fra i piedi.
Viaggiano di nuovo
e vengono di nuovo
in Italia,
vanno a Venezia
e intanto
Anna comincia
a pubblicare.
Lei scrive poesie
da quando era bambina
a 17 anni
pubblica
per la prima volta
su rivista
sulla rivista
di Lieff
di Nicolai
scusate
di suo marito
nel 1912
esce un libro
di versi
di Anna
lei ha 23 anni
e viene notata
viene recensita
e in realtà
queste sue poesie
hanno un enorme successo
immediatamente
diventa famosa.
Lei da vecchia
ostentava di dire
ma no
era una ragazzina scema
non capivo mica niente
chissà perché
quelle poesie stupide
che scrivevo allora
hanno avuto
tanto successo.
Cito
per qualche motivo
queste poesie infantili
scritte da una ragazzina
frivola
vennero ristampate
13 volte
e tradotte
in diverse lingue.
La ragazzina
lei per quanto mi ricordo
non l'aveva mica previsto
e nascondeva
sotto i cuscini
del sofà
le riviste
su cui venivano pubblicate.
Ora naturalmente
appunto
l'abbiamo detto
dobbiamo ridirlo
le autobiografie
non vanno necessariamente
prese alla lettera
specialmente
quelle dei letterati
e questa idea
della ragazzina
della ragazzina ingenua
che non capiva niente
momento
la ragazzina
era la moglie
di un poeta
molto conosciuto
e molto influente
di un critico
letterario
influente
a Pietroburgo
frequentavano
un ambiente
di poeti
di letterati
e lei diventa
rapidamente famosa
tant'è vero
che molti artisti
in questi anni
le fanno il ritratto
questo è del 14
se non ricordo male
ma ce n'è parecchi
di ritratti di Anna
e parecchi poeti
le dedicano poesie
salutandola
come
diciamo
il nuovo astro
della poesia russa
una poesia
di Sergei
Goradieschi
all'inizio
del secolo
la musa
si presentò
con un profilo
strano
affilato
e superbo
e risuonò
la voce
che aspettavamo
c'è anche
chi non la trova
tanto simpatica
e non ci casca
e la trova
un po'
una montatura
c'è una testimonianza
una testimonianza
no
un'osservazione
di uno scrittore
anche lui famoso
che poi andrà in esilio
con la rivoluzione
Bunin
Ivan Bunin
romanziera
all'epoca
molto famoso
che invece
la descrive così
in versi
il grande manicotto
con amoroso languore
premuto
alla guancia pallida
ginocchia spigolose
mano stretta
e anemica
nervosa
finta
intanto
il loro matrimonio
va avanti
malissimo
tutte e due
hanno un sacco
di storie
si tradiscono
c'è una poesia
di Gumilioff
in cui si rivolge
a Anna
e dice
lo so
nella vita
ho fallito
e a te
ti ho persa
al gioco
e poi arriva
inaspettato
da tutti
il 1914
e lo scoppio
della guerra mondiale
lo scopio
è il presagio
della fine
del mondo
c'è una poesia
di Anna
due anni dopo
nel 1916
in memoria
del giorno
in cui è scoppiata
la guerra
in cui dice
invecchiamo
di cent'anni
e questo
allora
accadde
in un'ora
sola
in realtà
poi sono
tutti quanti
travolti
come in tutti
i paesi europei
sta succedendo
all'inizio
sono tutti
travolti
dall'entusiasmo
nazionalistico
per la patria
dalla voglia
di sacrificarsi
per la patria
in questa guerra
santa
che tutti
tutti i popoli
in guerra
fra loro
vedono
e si vedono
presentare
dai loro governi
dalla stampa
come una guerra santa
anche in Russia
ci credono
Nicolai
parte volontario
per il fronte
e Anna
scrive
c'è una sua poesia
in cui scrive
implorando Dio
di salvare
la Russia
dicendo
guarda
piuttosto
mi sacrifico io
prendi me
prendimi tutto
prendimi il marito
prendimi il figlio
su marito
d'accordo
ma salva
la Russia
e molti anni dopo
un'altra grande poetessa
Marina Svetaiova
morta poi
suicida
nel 41
Marina Svetaiova
molti anni dopo
vedendo questa poesia
inorridì
e le disse
ma Anna Andreevna
ma cosa ha scritto
non doveva
non sa che la poesia
si avvera sempre
con la guerra
ovviamente
la vita spensierata
è finita
sono finiti
i giorni
delle feste
delle riunioni letterarie
arrivano
le privazioni
i disagi
la solitudine
anche il matrimonio
con Gumilyov
finisce
nel 18
divorziano
e la guerra
lascia il posto
alla rivoluzione
e la rivoluzione
lascia il posto
alla guerra civile
sono anni
e anni
dal 14
al 17
all'inizio del 18
la guerra
dal 17
in poi la rivoluzione
la guerra civile
sono anni di fame
sono anni di freddo
sono anni in cui
tanti scappano
anche Anna
per un po'
pensa
se non sia il caso
di andarsene
di emigrare
c'è una lettera
al marito
dell'agosto del 17
capite
nell'agosto del 17
è già caduto
lo zar
c'è il governo provvisorio
non c'è ancora stata
la rivoluzione
d'ottobre
non ci sono ancora
i bolshevichi
al potere
però
però Anna scrive
guardo con angoscia
quello che sta succedendo
in Russia
il signore
sta punendo
duramente
il nostro paese
poi lascia perdere
non se ne va
ovviamente
è cambiato tutto
tocca lavorare
e lei si impiega
come bibliotecaria
e intanto però
appena divorziato
da Gumilioff
si risposa
c'è la fila
fuori dalla porta
di Anna
degli innamorati
deve solo scegliere
si risposa
con un giovanotto
che di mestiere
studia gli assiri
un assiriologo
Valdemar Scileico
anche poeta
anche lui
e intanto però
e intanto però scrive
e appena
appena è possibile
in Russia
si ricomincia
a pubblicare riviste
a pubblicare poesie
nel 21
si ricomincia
a pubblicare libri
escono due
libri
di poesie
di Anna
che continua
a essere acclamata
come
il più grande
poeta russo
vivente
in quel momento
in quello stesso
suo marito
il suo ex marito
Nikolai Gumilyov
con cui lei
ha mantenuto
però in realtà
un rapporto
viscerale
complicatissimo
ma fortissimo
anche dopo il divorzio
nel 1921
viene fucilato
come
contro
rivoluzionario
poesie di Anna
sulla morte
di Gumilyov
non sarai più
tra i vivi
non ti alzerai
dalla neve
28 colpi
di baionetta
d'arma da fuoco
amara
la veste nuova
che cucivo
all'amico
piace
un po'
di sangue
alla terra
russa
dopodiché
la Russia
che è diventata
l'Unione Sovietica
esce dal bagno
di sangue
della guerra mondiale
della rivoluzione
della guerra civile
e in quegli anni venti
apparentemente
è piena di energia
è piena di vitalità
con una cultura
straordinaria
all'avanguardia
nel campo letterario
nel teatro
nel cinema
nella grafica
nella poesia
e pochi
non è vero
nessuno
qualcuno sì
ma pochi
presentano
che quasi tutti
i protagonisti
di quell'avanguardia
dieci anni dopo
o quindici anni dopo
saranno stritolati
dalle repressioni
staliniane
Anna scrive
ed è al culmine
della fama
è talmente popolare
che una scultrice
di Leningrado
adesso Pietroburgo
si chiama Leningrado
Natalia Danco
produce
crea
una statuetta
di porcellana
che è il ritratto
di Anna Akhmatova
a figura intera
e questa statuetta
di porcellana
viene prodotta
su grandissima scala
dalle fabbriche statali
dell'Unione Sovietica
la leggenda dice
in ogni casa
ce n'è una
naturalmente
non è vero
però viene prodotta
ininterrottamente
la producono ancora adesso
e l'originale
è all'Ermitage
e Anna in quegli anni
scrive
pubblica
c'è una sua poesia
in cui
in cui parla
della musa
quando di notte
attendo il suo arrivo
sembra che la vita
si appesa a un filo
cos'è il successo
la giovinezza
la libertà
in confronto
alla dolce ospite
col flauto in mano
ed ecco è entrata
scostato il velo
mi ha squadrata
attentamente
io le dico
sei tu
che hai dettato a Dante
le pagine dell'inferno?
mi risponde
sono io
Anna fra l'altro
aveva studiato l'italiano
per leggere Dante
in originale
lei è un amico
strettissimo
credo uno dei pochi
che non sono mai stati
innamorati di lei
non sono andati a letto
ma era un'amicizia letteraria
fortissima
con Ossip Mandelstam
che è un altro
dei grandi poeti russi
del novecento
lui non è sopravvissuto
a Stalin
e lui
Mandelstam è uno di quelli
che già negli anni venti
aveva capito
cosa stava per succedere
e in quegli anni
lei e Mandelstam
studiano l'italiano
per poter leggere Dante
Mandelstam ha scritto
poi anche un libro
su Dante
e c'è qualcuno
che ricorda
quando chiesero
ad Anna Akhmatova
in vecchiaia
lei ha letto Dante
con il suo tono
da grande regina
della poesia
rispose
non faccio altro
che leggere Dante
secondo qualcuno
che la osserva
in quegli anni
siamo sempre
nei primi anni venti
perde anche un po'
la testa
c'è anche qualcuno
che non si fa affascinare
che non cade in ginocchio
che riesce a guardarla
un po' in prospettiva
come un vecchio scrittore
Cornei Tchukovsky
molto molto popolare
povera donna
riesce a parlare
a pensare
solo alla sua notorietà
passa giornate intere
alla ricerca
di una riga sui giornali
in cui sia citata
il problema è che
le righe sui giornali
non sono più necessariamente
tutte favorevoli
perché in realtà
in quel paese
pieno di contraddizioni
ma che ormai
sta imboccando
una certa strada
ecco
mentre
mentre c'è chi
continua a scrivere
che lei è il più grande
poeta russo vivente
e lo scrive
la Pravda
a un certo punto
mentre c'è chi
cerca
intuendo
che forse
la sua poesia
non è proprio
questa poesia
diciamo così
intimista
ecco
da parte di una
aristocratica
del vecchio mondo
ecco
c'è qualcuno
che cerca di costruirle
un'altra immagine
in Unione Sovietica
ha una certa influenza
in quel momento
una donna
che si chiama
Alexandra Kollontai
è una rivoluzionaria
famosa
vecchia bolshevica
è stata ministro
nel governo di Lenin
fra parentesi
la prima donna
ministro
nella storia
poi adesso
ha un po' perso
di influenza
l'hanno mandata
a fare l'ambasciatore
dell'Unione Sovietica
in Norvegia
fra parentesi
la prima donna
ambasciatore
della storia
ecco Alexandra Kollontai
scrive che Anna
in realtà
si può sembrare
un'aristocratica
del vecchio mondo
ma non è vero
l'importante
è che è una donna
ed è
ed è una femminista
in realtà
nella sua poesia
c'è
c'è la difesa
della donna
la critica
proletaria
militante
invece
non se la beve
per la critica
proletaria
questa signorina
di buona famiglia
che scrive
dei suoi amori
e dei suoi amanti
ecco
nel nostro mondo
cosa ci sta a fare
è un avanzo
del passato
e alla fine
questa posizione
prevale
e Anna
nel giro
di poco tempo
scopre che di lei
non si parla più
e che quando
presenta le sue poesie
alle riviste
le dicono
no no mi dispiace
il numero è già pieno
e le case editrici
non le pubblicano
più niente
il suo ultimo libro
è del 24
poi per 16 anni
non le pubblicheranno
più niente
nel 25-26
c'era ancora
un'edizione
delle sue opere
omnia
in due volumi
già pronta
in bozze
la fermano
non esce
e anche lei
in realtà
anche lei
scrive sempre meno
tra la seconda
metà degli anni 20
e gli anni 30
Anna non scrive
quasi niente
lavorare
lavora poco
viveva per un po'
di questi libri
di diritti d'autore
siccome non vogliono
lasciarla morire di fame
le danno una pensione
e siccome l'Unione Sovietica
è un paese surreale
dove si può fare
tutto quello che si vuole
le danno una pensione
di vecchiaia
a 35 anni
però insomma
è quello il modo
per sistemarla
così evitiamo
che ci muoia di fame
e che all'estero
eh ma dove è conosciuta
facciamo delle storie
la moglie di Mandelstam
che è molto amica
di Anna
Nadiezhda Mandelstam
e che ha lasciato
un grosso volume
di memoria
in molto importanti
dirà
sì sì
la pensione
le bastava appena
per le sigarette
e per i fiammiferi
Anna non smette
praticamente di scrivere
e l'aveva anche
un po' preannunciato
ancora nell'ultimo momento
in cui aveva successo
e tutti parlavano di lei
c'è una sua poesia
che in qualche modo
presagisce questa cosa
il fastidio
di essere sotto
i riflettori
e la sensazione comunque
di non essere capita
e la voglia di sparire
io sono la vostra voce
il calore del vostro fiato
io sono il riflesso
del vostro volto
l'inutile palpito
di inutili ali
ma fa lo stesso
sono con voi
fino alla fine
ecco perché mi amate
così avidamente
nel mio peccato
nel mio male
ecco perché
mi avete dato
senza pensarci
il migliore
dei vostri figli
parla sempre
del marito fucilato
Nicolai
mi avete dato
senza pensarci
il migliore
dei vostri figli
ecco perché
non mi avete più
chiesto di lui
neanche una volta
e avete riempito
del fumo
di vuote lodi
la mia casa
svuotata
per sempre
e poi fa la parodia
di quello che scrivono
i critici di lei
e dicono
non si può fondersi
più strettamente
non si può amare
più perdutamente
così come l'ombra
vuole staccarsi
dal corpo
così come la carne
vuole separarsi
dall'anima
così io adesso
voglio essere
dimenticata
scrive sempre meno
scrive poco
intanto la sua vita
privata va avanti
tumultuosa
e traumatica
come sempre
nel 18
ha sposato
lo studioso
degli assiri
tre anni dopo
divorziano
pare
che il bravo
Valdemar Scileico
fosse geloso
e possessivo
è come dargli torto
a lei non va bene
e si mette
con un altro
un altro intellettuale
un grande storico
dell'arte
stavolta
Pugnin
Nicolai Pugnin
che frequentava
già da prima
adesso si mettono
insieme
non si sposano
tecnicamente
ma convivono
ufficialmente
convivono
siamo nell'unione
sovietica
degli anni venti
dopo la rivoluzione
c'è
la crisi degli alloggi
nelle grandi città
i palazzi
nobiliari
sono stati
confiscati
ci hanno mandato
a vivere
i proletari
dividendo
i grandi alloggi
dei nobili
una famiglia
in ogni stanza
adesso
magari anche di più
Pugnin
ha avuto
un alloggetto
in uno di questi
grandi palazzi
nobiliari
di Leningrado
sul canale
della Fontanca
nella vita
di Anna Akhmatova
questa è
la casa
sulla Fontanca
che è il luogo
mitico
della vita
di Anna
dove adesso
c'è uno
dei suoi musei
e Pugnin
ha questo alloggio
e Anna
va a vivere
con lui
peccato che
Pugnin
è divorziato
ma la ex moglie
e la figlia
non avendo avuto
un altro alloggio
vivono sempre lì
quindi vivono insieme
in un'altra stanza
però
e dal 28
si fa vivo
il figlio
Lief
ormai giovanotto
che vuole venire
a Leningrado
anche lui
e quindi
deve vivere anche lui
nella casa
sulla Fontanca
poi questo matrimonio
matrimonio
questa convivenza
con Pugnin
vabbè dopo un po'
anche loro
si stufano un po'
però comunque
rimarranno a vivere
sempre lì insieme
Anna
quando scrive
e scrive poco
scrive di infelicità privata
scrive di amori
che sono finiti male
c'è una poesia del 34
che si intitola
Ultimo Brindisi
io bevo a una casa distrutta
alla mia vita sciagurata
alla solitudine in due
e a te io bevo
all'inganno di labbra
che mi hanno tradita
a un occhio
di morto gelo
al fatto che il mondo
è rozzo e crudele
al fatto che Dio
non ci ha salvati
e fin qui
come dire
è la sofferenza
del privato
però naturalmente
c'è anche la tragedia
della rivoluzione
che sta divorando
i suoi figli
a cavallo
tra gli anni 20 e 30
e quando in una
sovietica
ormai nessuno
può più farsi illusione
in cui va il potere
Stalin
e quelli che si erano fatti
delle illusioni
cominciano a suicidarsi
e i primi che si suicidano
sono i poeti
che ci avevano creduto
gli esiegni nel 25
Mayakovsky
nel 30
il paese
gronda sangue
e nel 33
un'altra delle pochissime
poesie di questi anni
il miele selvatico
di libertà
sa il miele selvatico
la polvere
sa di raggio di sole
di viola
la bocca virginale
e l'oro
non sa di niente
l'erba
sa di acqua
e di mela
l'amore
ma noi abbiamo
imparato per sempre
che il sangue
sa solo di sangue
dopodiché
dopodiché le cose
vanno di male in peggio
perché anche
il terrore staliniano
si afferma
per gradi
a ondate successive
e l'ondata più tragica
è quella che si scatena
a partire dal dicembre
del 34
dopo l'assassinio
del capo
del partito
a Leningrado
Kirov
questo
questo omicidio
di cui tuttora
non si sa bene niente
se c'entri Stalin
se non c'entri
però certamente
è considerato
diciamo
il momento
in cui ufficialmente
si impone
il terrore
staliniano
e spazza
innanzitutto
Leningrado
dove appunto
è avvenuto
l'omicidio
tra gli altri
anche Lief
il figlio di Anna
è arrestato
nel 35
poi viene rilasciato
per stavolta
e intorno ad Anna
i conoscenti
gli amici
i letterati
i poeti
gli uomini di teatro
ogni tanto
si viene a sapere
che qualcuno
è stato arrestato
anche Ossip
Mandelstam
l'amico con cui
studiava Dante
viene arrestato
e poi
e poi se la cava
ancora bene
lo condannano
soltanto al confino
in provincia
di vieto
di risiedere
a Mosca
o Leningrado
poteva andargli
molto peggio
per il momento
a Ossip
Mandelstam
Anna dedica
una poesia
in cui fra l'altro
scrive
ma nella stanza
del poeta
in disgrazia
vegliano a turno
la paura
e la musa
e arriva la notte
che non vedrà
l'aurora
e in quegli anni
Anna come quasi tutti
si aspetta
di essere arrestata
da un momento
all'altro
c'è tanta gente
che tiene la valigia
pronta
anzi
a un certo punto
Anna comincia
a stupirsi
che non l'hanno
ancora arrestata
suo marito
Pugnin
le dice
ti tengono
per il gran finale
invece arrestano
di nuovo
suo figlio
Lief
nel 38
rimane un anno
e mezzo
in prigione
a Leningrado
nel carcere
delle Croci
la più grande
prigione
di Leningrado
poi viene
condannato
a morte
poi gli viene
commutata
la pena
al lager
starà in lager
pochi anni
perché nel 42
ai prigionieri
dei lager
viene offerto
la liberazione
se vanno
volontari in guerra
e Lief
andrà
a combattere
in guerra
contro i nazisti
uscirà
dal lager
per il momento
dunque
fra il 38
e il 39
Lief
è in prigione
per un anno
e mezzo
a Leningrado
e Anna
che tutti i giorni
va a fare la fila
davanti al carcere
con le mogli
e le figlie
e le donne
di tutti gli altri
arrestati
per sapere qualcosa
quando dopo ore
arrivi allo sportello
per poter lasciare
un pacco
Anna
in quel momento
comincia a scrivere
quello che è una
delle sue opere
più importanti
un ciclo
di poesie
che si intitola
Requiem
e che prova
a raccontare
appunto
questo
Requiem
ha un prologo
in prosa
in cui Anna
racconta
com'è che ha deciso
di scrivere
questa cosa
ho passato
17 mesi
in fila
davanti alle carceri
di Leningrado
una volta
qualcuno
mi riconobbe
allora
una donna
dalle labbra
livide
che stava
dietro di me
e che sicuramente
non aveva mai sentito
il mio nome
si riscosse
dal torpore
che era caratteristico
di tutti noi
e mi domandò
in un orecchio
lì tutti parlavano
sussurrando
ma questo
lei
può descriverlo
e io dissi
posso
allora
una specie
di sorriso
scivolò
lungo quello
che un tempo
era stato
in suo volto
vi leggo
una delle poesie
di questo ciclo
Requiem
se ti mostrassero
burlona
beniamina
di tutti gli amici
allegra
peccatrice
di Zarsko
Gieselò
cosa succederà
alla tua vita
come starai
in coda
con un pacco
trecentesima
davanti alle croci
a fondere
il ghiaccio
dell'anno nuovo
con le tue lacrime
bollenti
là il pioppo
della prigione
d'ondola
e non c'è
un suono
eppure
quante vite
innocenti
si concludono
là
e nell'epilogo
di Requiem
appunto
racconta
in versi
stavolta
come stando
in fila
davanti
alla prigione
davanti a quel muro
cieco
nel gelo
dell'inverno
e nell'afa
dell'estate
ha imparato
come appassiscono
i volti
come il dolore
scava le rughe
sulla faccia
come il sorriso
si trasforma
in ghigno
e i capelli
diventano bianchi
e dedica
Requiem
al ricordo
di tutte le donne
che erano lì
con lei
di nuovo
si avvicina
l'ora del ricordo
io vi vedo
vi ascolto
vi sento
quella che hanno dovuto
spingere
fino allo sportello
quella che veniva
da un altro paese
e quella che disse
scuotendo
il bel capo
io vengo qui
come a casa
volevo ricordarvi
tutte per nome
ma hanno preso
l'elenco
e non so come fare
e poi
sempre in Requiem
nella conclusione
di Requiem
nell'epilogo
profetizza
dice
se mi tapperanno
la bocca
la mia bocca
con cui grida
un popolo
di cento milioni
voi ricordatevi
di me lo stesso
e se invece
mi faranno
un monumento
che non lo facciano
vicino al mare
dove sono nata
o a Tsarsko
i Selò
dove quell'ombra
sconsolata
mi sta ancora cercando
sempre il marito
fucilato
fatemelo qui
il monumento
dove sono stata
in piedi
trecento ore
e dove non mi hanno
aperto i chiavi stelli
e aveva ragione
naturalmente
Marina Zvetajeva
le poesie
si avverano sempre
oggi
a Pietroburgo
che si chiama
di nuovo così
davanti alla prigione
delle croci
c'è il monumento
di Anna Akhmatova
uno dei quattro
monumenti
di Anna
che ci sono
a Pietroburgo
nel 1940
Requiem
è concluso
ovviamente
non solo
non si può pubblicare
ma guai
se le autorità
dovessero leggere
questi versi
è perfino
pericoloso
tenerlo in casa
scritto
Anna
lo impara
a memoria
e le amiche
lo imparano
a memoria
con lei
in modo
da poterlo
tramandare
qualunque cosa
succeda
c'è un ricordo
di una di queste amiche
Lidia
Lidia Tchukovskaya
che ricorda
quello che per loro
era diventato
il rito
del fiammifero
quando c'era
un pezzo pronto
nella sua casa
sulla fontanca
Anna
ad un tratto
nel bel mezzo
di un discorso
si interrompeva
e indicandomi
con gli occhi
il soffitto
e le pareti
dove c'erano
le cimici
i microfoni
nascosti
prendeva un pezzo
di carta
e una matita
poi diceva
ad alta voce
qualcosa di molto
frivolo
volete un tè
oppure
come siete
abbronzata
scriveva
velocemente
fino a riempire
il foglietto
e me lo porgeva
io leggevo i versi
e quando li avevo
imparati a memoria
glieli restituivo
in silenzio
l'autunno
quest'anno è venuto
presto
diceva Anna
ad alta voce
e acceso un fiammifero
bruciava il foglio
in un posacenere
eppure con tutto questo
quando
nell'anno
massimo del terrore
nel 38
viene arrestato
Pugnin
con cui lei ormai
ha deciso di separarsi
non sono più
compagni
però vivono sempre
nella stessa casa
perché non c'è modo
di andare da un'altra parte
quando viene arrestato Pugnin
Anna
scrive a Stalin
e Pugnin viene liberato
e nel 1940
pubblicano di nuovo
delle sue poesie
su delle riviste
e poi esce
una raccolta
un libro
finalmente
c'è una lettera
una lettera di un altro
lo capite
questo ambiente di scrittori
si conoscevano tutti
erano tutti legati
fra loro
passavano le notti
insieme a discutere
c'è una lettera
di Pasternak
l'autore del dottor
Zhivago
nonché premio Nobel
per la letteratura
anche lui
Pasternak
racconta
l'emozione collettiva
nel paese
quando esce
si viene a sapere
che esce
ogni nuovo
una raccolta
di versi
di Anna Akhmatova
e gli sforzi
della gente
per riuscire
a prenotare
a tutti i costi
una copia
e intanto
è scoppiata
la guerra mondiale
e Anna
ricomincia
a scrivere
vabbè
scusate
ho già ricominciato
con Requiem
però va avanti
va avanti
nel senso che
l'impatto
di quelle
o delle notizie
che arrivano
dal mondo
l'impatto
negativo
in realtà
sapete come comincia
la guerra
con le grandi vittorie
tedesche
con la guerra
Lampo
con la caduta
di Varsavia
la caduta
di Parigi
i bombardamenti
su Londra
e su tutte
queste cose
Anna scrive
scrive
quando i nazisti
sconfiggono
la Francia
e sfilano
vittoriosi
a Parigi
quando seppelliscono
un'epoca
non risuona
il salmo funebre
all'ortica
al cardo
tocca abbellirla
e solo i becchini
lavorano sodo
è un lavoro
urgente
e c'è silenzio
signore
un silenzio
che si sente
il tempo
che passa
ma poi lei
l'epoca
l'epoca seppellita
ma poi lei
torna a galla
come un cadavere
nel fiume
a primavera
ma il figlio
non riconosce
la madre
e il nipote
gira la faccia
angosciato
e si infossano
più in basso
le teste
e come un pendolo
si muove
la luna
ecco
così
su Parigi
perita
ora c'è
questo silenzio
e scrive anche
quando Londra
brucia
sotto i bombardamenti
della Luftwaffe
scrive
con un'immagine
sostanzialmente
dice
questa cosa
che sta succedendo
a Londra
è come se fosse
l'ultima tragedia
di Shakespeare
noi stiamo assistendo
a una nuova
tragedia di Shakespeare
e
ve la sto parafrasando
perché poi la leggo
ma non è così
è molto sintetica
e
vedendo quello
che succede
oggi a Londra
noi d'ora in poi
Shakespeare
lo capiremo meglio
e lo reciteremo meglio
però questo
non lo vorremmo recitare
il ventiquattresimo
dramma di Shakespeare
lo scrive
l'epoca
con un mano
che non trema
partecipi anche noi
del terribile festino
reciteremo meglio
Amleto
Cesare
Lir
sul fiume di Piombo
meglio
oggi
condurremo
alla tomba
con canti
e fiaccole
la dolce
Giulietta
spieremo meglio
dalla finestra
Macbeth
che rabbrividisce
insieme al sicario
solo
non questo
questo
non abbiamo più
la forza
di recitarlo
e in effetti
il 40 è un anno
terribile
da quel punto di vista
è un anno
in cui
in cui il pensiero
del suicidio
sfiora probabilmente
anche lei
e se non quello
certamente
è una sensazione
di morte
più forte
che in qualunque
altro momento
ah già
nel frattempo
Ossip
Mandelstam
è stato riarrestato
è sparito in Lager
da cui non tornerà
un'altra poesia
di Anna del 40
ma io vi avverto
che vivo
per l'ultima volta
né come rondine
né come acero
né come giunco
né come stella
non come acqua
di sorgente
o come suono
di campane
verrò più
a disturbare
la gente
non visiterò
i sogni altrui
con un lamento
non placato
e tuttavia
dopo 16 anni
di silenzio
lei è di nuovo
uno scrittore
riconosciuto
ufficialmente
pubblicato
nel 41
al momento
dell'invasione nazista
viene chiamata
a parlare
alla radio
e poi
sapete cosa succede
nei primissimi mesi
dell'invasione tedesca
dell'operazione barbarossa
i tedeschi avanzano
con una rapidità spaventosa
arrivano alle porte
di Leningrado
decidono
anziché conquistarla
di isolarla
e lasciarla
morire di fame
Leningrado
viene assediata
l'assedio
durerà anni
e nei primi mesi
prima che i russi
riescano ad aprire
una via di rifornimento
attraverso il mare
ghiacciato
il lago ghiacciato
nei primi mesi
Leningrado
è completamente
isolata
5-600 mila
persone
muoiono
di fame
in quei mesi
in cui il paese
sta crollando
il governo
sovietico
trova anche
il tempo
di evacuare
da Leningrado
le persone
più importanti
e vengono evacuati
fra gli altri
gli scrittori
gli artisti
e viene evacuata
Anna
lei e Pugnin
l'ex compagno
li trasferiscono
in Asia
in Uzbekistan
a Tashkent
dove passeranno
la guerra
e lei
in quell'occasione
è di nuovo
una persona
che può
ottenere qualcosa
quando chiede
fa evacuare
anche la vedova
di Ossip Mandelstam
che
in quanto vedova
di un nemico
del popolo
non ha diritti
praticamente
e certamente
nessuno si preoccuperebbe
di evacuare
lei
resterebbe a morire
di fame
a Leningrado
invece Anna
riesce a portarsela
dietro
se la porta dietro
a Tashkent
divide con lei
le sue razioni
o più tardi
sarà evacuata
anche la scultrice
Natalia Danco
quella che aveva fatto
la statua
di Anna
viene evacuata
con la madre
con la sorella
però troppo tardi
nel senso
che hanno fatto
talmente tanta fame
che muoiono
muoiono poco dopo
tutte e tre
e così Anna
vive
ancora gli anni
della guerra
al sicuro
sono anni
ovviamente
di immensa povertà
per tutti
però
una poetessa
importante
ha delle razioni
che le permettono
di sopravvivere
e di far sopravvivere
anche
la vedova
di Mandelstam
che vive con lei
e poi nel 45
nel 45
si torna
a Leningrado
e a Leningrado
succede
un episodio
che avrà
conseguenze
enormi
sugli ultimi anni
di vita
di Anna
sia positive
sia tragiche
va a trovarla
un signore
uno straniero
un celebre
filosofo inglese
che si chiama
Isaiah Berlin
che peraltro
è un ebreo russo
di nascita
anche se
è emigrato
da tantissimo tempo
in Inghilterra
è un personaggio
che conta
in Inghilterra
un intellettuale famoso
ed è segretario
dell'ambasciata britannica
a Mosca
e trovandosi
in Russia
decide di andare
a trovare
Anna Akhmatova
a Leningrado
va a trovarla
restano a parlare
tutta la notte
lei ormai
ha più di 50 anni
lui è molto più giovane
di lei
ha 20 anni di meno
a Isaiah Berlin
si ricorda benissimo
di questo incontro
la casa
era quasi vuota
praticamente
tutto quello
che c'era dentro
a quanto ho capito
era sparito
rubato
o venduto
durante l'assedio
una signora
con i capelli grigi
imponente
con uno scialle
bianco
sulle spalle
si alzò lentamente
per riceverci
Anna Akhmatova
aveva una dignità
immensa
si muoveva
senza fretta
una testa nobile
bella
lineamenti
abbastanza severi
è un'espressione
di immensa tristezza
ora
quest'anziana signora
dai lineamenti
severi
l'espressione triste
si innamora
come una ragazzina
di questo giovanotto
che è arrivato
a trovarla
grande intellettuale
meravigliosa conversazione
uno straniero
ecco
si innamora perdutamente
rimane innamorata
per anni e anni e anni
lui no
lui la ricorda con affetto
però
lei invece parte
completamente
per anni
scrive poesie
dedicate
a lui
una poesia scritta
più di dieci anni dopo
tu mi hai inventata
una così al mondo
non c'è
non può esserci
il medico
non la guarirà
il poeta
non potrà saziarla
l'ombra del fantasma
ti angoscerà
giorno e notte
ha promesso
di non tornare più
ma insomma
ha già cambiato idea
noi
ci siamo incontrati
in un anno inconcepibile
il 45 appunto
quando si erano esaurite
le energie
del mondo
tutto era in lutto
tutto si piegava
sotto la sventura
ed erano fresche
solo le tombe
e tu sei venuto a me
come guidato
da una stella
attraversando
un tragico autunno
in quella casa
svuotata per sempre
da cui si levava
uno stormo
diversi
bruciati
e questa è la conseguenza
diciamo così positiva
la conseguenza tragica
è che questa
in un'unione sovietica
che finita la guerra
sta sprofondando
in una repressione staliniana
molto più paranoica
e irrazionale
di quanto non fosse stata prima
in cui in particolare
la paura degli stranieri
il timore degli stranieri
delle spie
è diventato
una dimensione
onnipresente
della vita collettiva
basta il fatto
che il giovane
diplomatico straniero
è andato a trovare
l'anziana poetessa
perché le autorità
si mettono in allarme
e ricominciano
a occuparsi
di Anna
e decidono
stavolta
che effettivamente
il fatto che abbia di nuovo
tutto questo successo
non va bene
e così
sulla Pravda
nel 46
esce
una risoluzione
firmata
da un personaggio
importante
dell'unione sovietica
di allora
Zhdanov
Andrea Aleksandrovich
protagonista
della difesa
di Leningrado
e poi
protagonista
della gestione
della cultura
negli anni
del dopoguerra
è impegnato
a ripulire
la cultura sovietica
dalle influenze
del capitalismo
e dai residui
del passato
in questo testo
che pubblicato
sulla Pravda
acquista il carattere
quasi di una legge
di una risoluzione
ufficiale del governo
che indica
la linea da seguire
Anna Akhmatova
e un altro scrittore
famoso
un autore di racconti
Mikhail Zoshenko
vengono
indicati
come appunto
relitti
del passato
che non ha più
nessun senso
tollerare
nella nostra
società socialista
e di Anna
in particolare
Zhdanov scrive
questo residuato
della vecchia cultura
aristocratica
ora monaca
ora sgualdrina
o piuttosto
insieme
monaca e sgualdrina
in cui la dissolutezza
si mescola
alla preghiera
il giorno
in cui esce
l'articolo di Zhdanov
Anna
va a sbrigare
una pratica
in uno degli uffici
che gestiscono
la vita dei letterati
il fondo
per la letteratura
va lì
e lì tutti
hanno letto
il giornale
e se la vedono
arrivare
e rimangono
sbigottiti
per come
tranquilla
fa come se
niente fosse
rimangono
tutti ammiratissimi
lei poi dirà
che non aveva letto
il giornale
ne è sentito
la radio
perché la lettera
di Zhdanov
l'articolo di Zhdanov
è una cosa
di una tale importanza
che viene ripubblicato
su tutti i giornali
è letto
alla radio
e lei
non aveva saputo
niente
tornando a casa
ha comprato
una ringa
per pranzo
e a casa
svolgendo
il giornale
in cui era
incartata la ringa
ha letto
il suo nome
una cosa
del genere
è una cosa
che non solo
ti cambia la vita
può anche
essere il preannuncio
di qualcosa
di molto peggio
Anna comincia
a bruciare
lettere
e manoscritti
aspettando
da un momento
all'altro
che vengano
a prenderla
i suoi amici
che sono in vacanza
è agosto
molti suoi amici
sono in vacanza
al mare
o nei paesi baltici
tornano tutti
immediatamente
a Leningrado
anche se
nell'unione sovietica
del 46
per trovare
i biglietti
del treno
di solito
bisogna prenotarli
sei mesi prima
e riuscire
a cambiare programma
e arrivare di nuovo
a casa
all'improvviso
ti costa un'ira
di Dio
di bustarelle
però tutti i suoi amici
tornano
una sua amica
di Mosca
viene a Leningrado
a stare con lei
poi dopo qualche giorno
se la porta a casa sua
a Mosca
sono tutti lì
col fiato sospeso
aspettando che la vengano
ad arrestare
intanto la espellolo
dall'unione degli scrittori
ovviamente
e viene annullata
immediatamente
la pubblicazione
di due suoi libri
che erano già pronti
per la stampa
e per capirci
per capire cosa voleva dire
essere un poeta
invece ufficialmente
riconosciuto
e approvato
per uno di quei libri
era prevista
una tiratura
di centomila copie
per un libro di poesie
non so se avete presente
da noi
cosa sono le tirature
dei libri di poesie
ecco
tutto annullato
si crea subito
la leggenda
che c'è un episodio
specifico
non so
l'attacco di Zdanov
e la decisione
quindi di Stalin
di distruggere Anna
e Zoschenko
ma specialmente Anna
si crea subito
la leggenda
che c'è un episodio
particolare
c'è stata una serata
letteraria
una lettura pubblica
di poesie
poco tempo prima
e quando è entrata
la Akhmatova
tutto il pubblico
si è alzato in piedi
ad applaudirla
ed è rimasto in piedi
per dieci minuti
e in Unione Sovietica
solo Stalin
può essere applaudito
in piedi
per dieci minuti
non va bene
che possa succedere
a qualcun altro
Anna era sicura
che c'era questa cosa
dietro
dietro la sua disgrazia
anche questa
fa parte della leggenda
naturalmente
quello che non è
una leggenda
invece è il fatto
che Stalin
di queste cose
si occupava personalmente
perché
l'ho già detto ieri
mi scuso
con chi l'ha già sentito
in questo paese
sconvolgente
che era l'Unione Sovietica
il governo
che si occupava
di gestire
una superpotenza mondiale
e mandava a morire
o nei lager
la gente
senza pensarci due volte
dava un'importanza
immensa
a ogni riga
scritta
dagli scrittori
e dai poeti
e il governo
discuteva
direttamente
che cosa
si doveva fare
se pubblicare
o non pubblicare
ci sono
dei verbali
di riunioni
in cui
Stalin
incontra
i dirigenti
delle associazioni
degli scrittori
e chiede
allora
questa comatova
ma scrive ancora
vale ancora la pena
di pubblicarla
ma non è un relitto
del passato
ah sì
effettivamente
però queste poesie
non sono poi così male
a me non sembra
chi l'ha pubblicata
la tale rivista
ah
faremo i conti
ecco
e quindi
non c'è dubbio
che la decisione
di dare una lezione
alla comatova
è stata approvata
da Stalin
come anche il fatto
che però
non viene nessuno
ad arrestarla
in un momento
appunto
alla fine degli anni 40
in cui di nuovo
stanno arrestando
viene arrestato
suo figlio
di nuovo
nel 49
è condannato
a 10 anni
di lager
sarà liberato
nel 56
quando ci sarà
la destalinizzazione
il rapporto
di Khrushchev
rimanderanno a casa
gran parte
dei prigionieri
dei lager
anche Pugnin
l'ex marito
o l'ex compagno
viene arrestato
secondo la leggenda
Pugnin
che era uno storico
dell'arte
viene arrestato
per aver detto
che tutti quei ritratti
di Lenin
che c'erano in giro
erano di pessimo gusto
stavolta finisce
in lager
e stavolta
Anna non può aiutarlo
e ci morirà
proprio poco prima
che comincino
le liberazioni
però nel 48
intanto è morto
anche Zdanov
di infarto
ed è come
se morto lui
Stalin
avesse lasciato capire
che con Anna Akhmatova
basta così
che non è più
il caso di insistere
perché sta di fatto
che sui giornali
si ricomincia
a parlare di lei
voi capite
che ritmo
infatti
in questi anni
una delle cose
che gli amici di Anna
le sentono dire
ci sono già passate
un'altra volta
dalle centomila copie
agli insulti
ecco
ci sono già passate
un'altra volta
la riammettono
nell'unione degli scrittori
poi muore Stalin
le propongono
di pubblicare
un nuovo libro
uscirà
anche se dopo qualche anno
ovviamente il quadro
non dobbiamo farcelo
troppo rosio
anche dopo la morte
di Stalin
l'attenzione del potere
sugli scrittori
continua a essere
come dire
isterica
Anna fra l'altro
sta male
ha già avuto
un infarto
ne avrà degli altri
e c'è questo episodio
molto significativo
siamo nel 54
c'è un gruppo
di studenti inglesi
in visita
in unione sovietica
e dal partito
la invitano
lei
e l'altro scrittore
che era stato attaccato
da Shdanov
Zoshenko
li invitano
a incontrare
questi scrittori inglesi
Anna
siamo quasi alla fine
Anna non ci vorrebbe andare
perché ormai
lo sa come funzionano le cose
perché mettersi
in una situazione così
insistono
la mandano a prendere
la portano a incontrare
gli studenti inglesi
e gli studenti inglesi
sono abbastanza ingenui
da chiedere
prima a Zoshenko
e poi ad Anna
ma cosa ne pensate
di questa aggressione
di Shdanov
contro di voi
di qualche anno fa
e Zoshenko
dice
io ci sono rimasto
molto male
non era giusto
e gli studenti inglesi
applaudono
e poi chiedono ad Anna
Anna poi dirà
se l'avessero chiesto
prima a me
Zoshenko avrebbe capito
invece l'hanno chiesto
prima a lui
Anna quando le chiedono
si alza e dice
io sono assolutamente
d'accordo
con la risoluzione
di Shdanov
erano tutte cose giuste
e si risiede
nel gelo
gli studenti inglesi
non applaudono
Zoshenko sarà rovinato
per quello che ha detto
quel giorno
e ad Anna invece
non torceranno
un capello
anzi
sui giornali
usciranno
gli articoli
e la compagna
Akhmatova
ha dato una bella lezione
a quegli imperialisti
ha dimostrato lealtà
lei fra l'altro
dirà anche
si si
Zoshenko
è stato coraggioso
ma lui non aveva
un figlio in lager
Anna ce l'ha
due anni dopo
però esce
nel 56
esce Liev
ed esce
furibondo
con la madre
ma come
tu conti
ti intervistano
ti pubblicano
e non hai fatto niente
per farmi uscire
e non lo recupereranno
mai più
un rapporto
fra l'altro
poco prima
l'anno prima
nel lager
dove era detenuto
Liev
è arrivato
uno scrittore
che ha tenuto
ai detenuti
una conferenza
sulla situazione
della letteratura
in Unione Sovietica
perché succedeva
anche questo
e poi dopo la conferenza
Liev gli ha detto
sai io sono il figlio
dell'Ahmato
ma come sta la mamma
e il conferenziere
ha risposto
oh sta benissimo
scrive
pubblica
Liev quando esce
non lo vuole neanche vedere
cioè si va
però poi litigano
immediatamente
non avranno
praticamente più rapporti
tanto che quando Anna
alla fine sarà in ospedale
prima di morire
gli amici decideranno
di non lasciare
che lui vada a trovarla
perché hanno paura
che non regga
questi ultimi anni
di Anna però
sono gli anni appunto
di una poetessa
ormai ufficialmente
riconosciuta
e se Dio vuole
non cambierà più
la linea
e le danno
una dacia
in campagna
il Kagebe continua
a spiarla
naturalmente
come spiano tutti
c'è un rapporto
del 58
che descrive
tutto quello
che fa Anna
Akhmato
ogni giorno
ogni momento
della sua giornata
i suoi problemi
di salute
va spesso
al cimitero
che dista
un chilometro e mezzo
dalla Dacia
l'impressione
è che si stia
cercando un posto
in realtà però
il rapporto dice anche
che è pieno di progetti
che vuole scrivere
la sua autobiografia
e soprattutto
e questa è veramente
l'ultima cosa importante
soprattutto
non è sola
perché
perché per i giovani
poeti di Leningrado
lei è un mito
è una leggenda vivente
e vanno a trovarla
c'è questo gruppetto
di giovani poeti
tutti maschi
che vanno a trovarla
regolarmente
alla Dacia
e passano il tempo
con lei
a bere
a fumare
a leggerle
le loro poesie
le portano i fiori
e il bello
è che Anna
noi abbiamo le sue fotografie
era una vecchia
ingrossata
gonfia
malata
tutti questi giovanotti
dicono
era bellissima
il più famoso di loro
è Josef Brodsky
di cui parlerò domani
premio Nobel
per la letteratura
nell'87
allora era un ragazzo
Brodsky
la descrive così
era semplicemente
fisicamente
visibilmente
bella
grandi occhi azzurri
tipo
avete presente
il leopardo delle nevi
un naso tremendo
è stata una
delle donne più belle
del secolo
credo
una testa
pazzesca
e ancora
sempre Brodsky
era altissima
io sono un metro e settantotto
che per la Russia
non è mica male
insomma
non mi sono mai preoccupato
della mia statura
tranne quando camminavo
accanto a lei
perché era veramente alta
guardandola
capivi come mai
in certi momenti
la Russia
è stata governata
da un'imperatrice
Anna Akhmatova
aveva un chedi imperiale
aveva anche gli aspetti
come dire
più prepotenti
e delle imperatrici
come testimonia
l'aneddoto
a suo modo terribile
di Nadiesda
Mandelstam
la vedova
del suo amico
Ossip
sua amica
a cui lei ha salvato
la vita
sono legatissime
molto anziana
Nadiesda
a un certo punto
dice io adesso
però sono stanca
io aspetto solo
di morire
perché lassù
sarò di nuovo
con Ossip
e Anna risponde
non hai capito
niente
con Ossip
lassù ci starò io
ancora Brodsky
era una bevitrice
formidabile
se c'è stato qualcuno
che sapeva bere
era la Akhmatova
ed è diventata
una gloria patria
anche se le autorità
continuano a sorvegliare
quello che si scrive
su di lei
è veramente surreale
vedere questa cosa
esce nel 62
una piccola enciclopedia
letteraria
il primo volume
nel primo volume
c'è la voce
Akhmatova
naturalmente
i redattori
chiedono
al Politburo
al governo supremo
dell'Unione Sovietica
cosa devono scrivere
nella voce
sull'Ahmatova
e se possono evitare
di citare
gli insulti
di Shdanov
Sgualdrina
eccetera
il governo
dell'Unione Sovietica
si riunisce
e poi risponde
con una risoluzione
in cui dice
sì
gli insulti
potete anche
non citarli
dopodiché
esce l'enciclopedia
e il comitato centrale
del partito comunista
dedica un'intera seduta
a discutere
questa enciclopedia
letteraria
e a individuare
gli errori
che bisogna segnalare
perché hanno scritto
e comunque
la lasciano andare
all'estero
nel 64
viene in Italia
dopo 50 anni
che non ci tornava
perché le danno un premio
il premio
Etna Taormina
viene qui
va a Catania
va a Taormina
nel 65
le danno la laurea
onoris causa
all'università di Oxford
ha intorno
i suoi giovani
e ha un infarto
dopo l'altro
a un certo momento
decide di fare
testamento
e c'è
la storia
raccontata appunto
da uno di questi ragazzi
Anatoly Naiman
questi giovani poeti
lei gli ha chiesto
di accompagnarla
dal notaio
per fare testamento
perché c'è il notaio
in unione sovietica
e si fa il testamento
accompagna dal notaio
quando esce
è molto stanca
dopo aver fatto le scale
si rivolge
a questo giovanotto
che la tiene sotto braccio
e gli fa
ma di quale eredità
parliamo poi
quando sarà il momento
mettiti sotto il braccio
il disegno di Modi
e fila via
morirà poco dopo
del suo quarto infarto
e nel centenario
della sua nascita
Brodsky
che a quel punto
è in America
e premio Nobel
scrive una poesia
in cui la ringrazia
per quello che ha scritto
e finisce così
la ringrazia
per le sue parole
sta parlando
delle parole di Anna
un inchino
attraverso il mare
per averle trovate
a te
e alla tua parte mortale
che dorme
nel paese natio
il quale ringrazia te
per aver avuto
il dono della parola
nell'universo sordomuto
grazie a tutti
grazie
per fortuna
non c'è Stalin
ad ascoltare
grazie
e con chi ci sarà
a domani sera
allora
arrivederci
grazie
a